welcome back i was running out of time
the last video and I was afraid that I
was jumbling up the problem just to get
under the wire so what I just drew the
triangle and actually let me let me do
it over since I have all the time in the
world now because I really want you to
get this so they draw the try the
original parallelogram looks like this
the original parallelogram looks
something like this this is a diagonal
and they tell us that all of these sides
all of these sides are congruent so that
means that they're all the same length
so this side is equal to this side is
equal to this side to this side is equal
to the side so that also tells these are
both equilateral triangles right all the
sides are equal so all the these angles
this must be 60 this must be 60 this
must be 60 this must be 60 60 and 60 now
what else do we know well they want us
to figure out the ratio of this debt oh
whoops none do they want us to figure
out the ratio of this diagonal the long
diagonal to this shorter diagonal right
here right we know the shorter diagonals
of length 1 and with four out
parallelograms you might already kind of
know this and actually I could we could
prove this to you since these all of
these lines are congruent we know that
we know what what is this angle right
here what is half of this line is going
to bisect both of these angles right how
do we know well if it didn't bisect it
it wouldn't it all the sides wouldn't be
congruent so we know that this side is
30 this side is 30 this is 30 this is 30
and we also know that for any
parallelogram the the two actually for
any rhombus the two the two diagonals
are going to be perpendicular bisectors
of each other it's not true for any for
any parallelogram it's only true when
the sides are all congruent so
in this situation this is and we already
know this because this is a 30 degree
angle this is a 60 degree angle so what
does this have to be this has to be a 90
degree angle right because they have to
add up to 180 so we let's just pick
number so let's say that this side is
one this site is one the side is one the
site is one then this entire diagonal
here would be one half of it would be
one half this would be one half we want
to have if we didn't know is one half we
could just say well this is a 30 60 90
triangle so the 30-degree side is one
half of the hypotenuse and then what
else do we know about 30 60 90 triangles
the 60-degree side is square root of
three times the shorter side so this
side is going to be square root of 3
over 2 and all we did is we used we
realize that this is a 30 60 90 triangle
and then we're using the principle of 30
60 90 triangle to figure out that the
side opposite the 60-degree side is
square root of 3 over 2 if that's side
square root of 3 over 2 then this is
also square root of 3 over 2 so what's
this entire length it be square root of
3 over 2 plus square root of 3 over 2
which is equal to square root of three
you had two halves with anything you get
the whole so just square roots of 3 so
the purple diagonal squares two three
and what is this you know this was D and
C this is AC sorry a C so we know that
AC is equal to square root of three and
we also know that d I'm sorry this is a
b DB is equal to 1 we just define this
one so the ratio of AC to be d or DB is
going to be square root of three two one
and that is choice B I hope I didn't
confuse you next section actually we
just finished that section I'll see you
soon